vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela blandono Buenos días para usted
Daniela Hola Buenos días Ángela y son
buenos porque el acuerdo del techo de la
deuda en Estados Unidos pasó la que
sería su prueba más dura no Claro que sí
avanza Está avanzando rápidamente para
que sea aprobado antes del 5 de junio
cuando dicen que se va a quedar sin caja
para operar este país la mayor Economía
del mundo este pacto ha negociado por
Joe biden y su rival Kevin mccarthy que
pretende evitar el primer incumplimiento
de la historia del país fue aprobado
entonces en la cámara de representantes
Este era el tramo más espinoso del
trámite legislativo pues allí dominan
los republicanos ahora la discusión pasa
al senado en donde los demócratas tienen
la mayoría más detalles en el siguiente
informe
los sí son 314 los no son 117 se aprueba
el proyecto de ley
con esos resultados el proyecto para la
suspensión del techo de la deuda superó
la revisión en la cámara de
representantes continuando así con el
trámite en el congreso de la iniciativa
del presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden y el líder republicano de la
cámara baja Kevin mccarthy la resolución
fue celebrada desde la Casa Blanca
esta noche la cámara dio un paso
fundamental para evitar un
incumplimiento de pago por primera vez y
proteger la histórica recuperación
económica de nuestro país ganada con
tanto esfuerzo este acuerdo
presupuestario es un compromiso
bipartidista por su parte el republicano
mccarthy quien ha quedado en el ojo de
las críticas de miembros de su propio
partido por los términos del acuerdo
también se mostró conforme con la
decisión de la cámara baja
history esta noche Todos hemos hecho
historia porque este es el mayor recorte
y Ahorro que este congreso ha votado
nunca Y no es que solo lo votemos Esto
va a ser ley
ahora el proyecto pasará la próxima
instancia el senado el presidente pidió
a la cámara alta que lo apruebe lo antes
posible ante los avisos de que el debate
podría extenderse durante el fin de
semana dominado estrechamente por los
demócratas el senado deberá debatir y
sancionar favorablemente la iniciativa
para llevarla al escritorio al
presidente para ser sancionada antes del
próximo lunes 5 de junio Pues bien eso
en cuanto a Cómo va avanzando este
acuerdo a lo largo del Congreso pero
también Daniela creo que sería muy
importante y le agradezco por traernos
el tema sobre cómo se ha comportado la
deuda de los Estados Unidos en las
últimas presidencias es algo pues como
mínimo sorprendente Claro porque ha ido
en ascenso Y es que siempre sucede en
este tipo de negociaciones Y es que los
políticos y los analistas tratan de
señalar con el dedo Quién es el culpable
de una deuda tan exorbitante en la
nación vamos a verlo en el siguiente
gráfico ya mencionar algunos hechos
basados en las estadísticas pues mire la
deuda primero hay que decirlo se mide
como porcentaje del producto interno
bruto porque puede que el país esté muy
endeudado pero al mismo tiempo está
generando más en su actividad económica
entonces lo que se hace Es medirlo con
relación al producto interno bruto como
lo vemos acá
en el gobierno de Barack Obama él empezó
con un 77% de proporción dentro del
producto interno bruto el siete por
ciento correspondía deuda y el término
con un 105% de
deuda sobre producto interno bruto
Donald Trump también me molesta
estadística y Joe biden pues muchos
dicen que la deuda durante el gobierno
de Trump fue la más alta pues lo cierto
Es que la deuda aumentó más durante el
mandato de Obama que en el de Donald
Trump Así mismo Pues Trump hay que
decirlo se enfrentó a la pandemia del
cobi 19 lo que provocó el apoyo
bipartidista para una respuesta Federal
masiva Y eso genera desde luego más
endeudamiento y en el periodo de biden
ha bajado inclusive esa proporción desde
que comenzó su mandato no ha terminado
Pero sí hay que ver cómo termina su
mandato la deuda sí ha venido en ascenso
en 2016 era de 19,5 billones de dólares
hoy ya va en más de 31 millones de
dólares en otros temas pero siguiendo en
Estados Unidos Daniela si las cuentas no
me fallan la anterior huelga de
guionistas duró cerca de 100 aquí ya
vamos más de 30 y sin un acuerdo a la
vista Pues el primero de mayo pasado fue
cuando más de 15.000 500 miembros del
sindicato de guionistas dejó de trabajar
exigiendo mejores condiciones laborales
y hasta el momento no parece haber una
salida eso no solamente causó
traumatismos primero en la serie es en
vivo también en algunas películas sino
que también toda una industria que se
mueve alrededor se ha visto bastante
afectado vemos como por ejemplo
shank quien es el copropietario de una
tienda de vestuario el ya había sentido
los efectos financieros de los cierres
de producción durante el covid 19 y ya
cuando estaba comenzando a recuperarse
decidió relanzar su negocio en enero
pasado pues este negocio dependía casi
en su totalidad de las producciones de
cine y televisión y escuchamos qué fue
lo que pasó ahora
definitivamente estamos sintiendo los
efectos financieros afortunadamente
hemos tenido algunos eventos que han
ayudado pero no el dinero que
necesitamos es apenas una ayuda en el
momento en que ocurrió la huelga comencé
a entrar en pánico
tenemos que pagar las cuentas y pagarle
a la gente no puedes golpear a una
persona en la cabeza y arrastrarla aquí
para que adquiere ropa
Ángela entonces para entender la
dimensión de esto Esta huelga ha
afectado a personal de apoyo asistentes
de los show runners asistentes de
producción y es que un día de producción
en el plató por ejemplo genera cientos
de miles de dólares para la economía
local en California Pues de allí
dependen trabajadores que vas desde
constructores de escenarios hasta
servicios de artesanías peluquería
maquillaje todo un engranaje alrededor
de esta industria pues qué haríamos
nosotros sin cesar o sin adilia o sin la
gente que nos colabora con el tema
técnico que trabajan muy duramente Pero
además es Daniela a todas las
consecuencias que esto trae dentro del
espectro que son los usuarios y que son
los trabajadores
lo Seguiremos cubriendo y ojalá que se
encuentre un acuerdo Próximamente vamos
a hacer un cambio de tema vamos a pasar
a la zona Euro el desempleo está en
mínimos históricos y la inflación cede
sin embargo las autoridades dicen que no
hay que cantar Victoria Pues no hay que
cantarla todavía porque primero miremos
los datos por un lado el desempleo en
los 20 países que comparten el euro
descendió una décima en abril con
respecto a marzo está en 6,5% y está en
un nuevo mínimo histórico esto según la
oficina de estadística comunitaria
eurostat también fue revelado el más
reciente dato de inflación que da cuenta
de que se desaceleró en nueve décimas
desde el 7% que iban abril anual hasta
el 6,1% en mayo pero el escenario está
muy lejos de lo que quieren las
autoridades por ejemplo en Alemania si
bien la variación del precio de la
canasta familiar están 6% es
relativamente bajo si se compara con
meses anteriores también lleva tres
meses desacelerándose pues la inflación
de alimentos sí es del 15% casi el
triple de lo que es el total de la
canasta familiar eso ha hecho que mucha
gente acuda por primera vez a los bancos
de alimentos
ahora viene gente que está al límite de
sus ingresos dicen que los precios han
subido mucho y ahora vienen al banco de
alimentos antes se las arreglaban con su
dinero estábamos entregando comida a 100
120 hogares justo hasta que estalló la
Guerra de Ucrania y ahora Estamos en 200
pues la situación es tal que la
presidenta del Banco Central europeo
Christine lagart subrayó este jueves que
la entidad debe subir más sus tipos de
interés porque la inflación está siendo
muy elevada y otros opinan lo contrario
pues Daniela de todas maneras yo no creo
que sean tiempos de vacas gordas yo creo
que son tiempos y no solamente en la
eurozona sino en todo el mundo de
revisar muy bien Cuáles son nuestros
gastos y nuestros modos de vida vamos si
le parece con su cifra
11.700 millones de dólares eso se
comprometió a invertir la minera china
resources en proyectos de litio en
Argentina así lo reveló el ministro de
economía Sergio massa quien está de
visita en este país asiático y se reunió
con directivos de esa empresa y no es
para menos Argentina es el cuarto mayor
productor mundial del litio que es un
metal muy demandado por los fabricantes
de vehículos eléctricos porque De allí
es que salen las baterías Daniela
Muchísimas gracias Bueno nos vemos acá
en una hora pero claro con más temas de